[Musique]
moi j'suis pas un grade en a mais j'ai
le goût de faire la radio je parle pour
une journée on est deux c'est pas
extrêmes mais c'est quand même assez
physique qu'est ce que je dois faire que
je te vois pas faire on part une journée
on peut tout est simple si je savoure
plaisait on part du principe que dans
cette journée là on mangerait on boirait
faut juste rajouter un petit extra avec
moi ce que je dis c'est pense à ce que
tu aurais manger si tu étais resté à la
maison
il faut ajouter un petit peu plus à ce
que j'aime beaucoup moins à porter c'est
ce qu'on appelle le goff good or bad
gones au pilote dans lego on va mélanger
du sucré salé pour surprendre les
papilles de ça pour moi ça va être ce
qui va maintenir pendant toute la
journée on va partir parce gros de
cheminement classique qui est super
simple qui se mange facilement
c'est une grande tortilla de blé entier
beurre d'arachide mieux que je roule
même que quand xinmao de saison où j'en
fais régulièrement logement préparé
plusieurs jeux les emballe congélateur
qu'il matin et soir avec ça je mange un
fruit
je vais avoir un café au lait parce que
j'aime beaucoup ce puits logement
pouvoir alors quand j'arrive sur le
sentier je suis hydrater et j'ai mangé
par ailleurs moi j'adore les salades
fait que je vois ma portée pour une
journée comme ça ça va être une salade
de repos l'attend avec quelque chose de
consistant quinoa ribul gourou out
et puisqu'on va boire est super
important aussi parce que ça si je
manque de liquide bien souvent ressenti
qu'on n'a pas d'énergie un petit mal de
tête mais c'est souvent de la
déshydratation plus qu'autre chose
alors c'est important est ce qu'il faut
manger un petit peu tout le long de la
journée où il faut s'arrêter faire des
pauses puis le substantiel c'est
préférable manger et boire toute la
journée
d'abord l'énergie va être plus
facilement assimilé à va être plus
disponible en continu et pour les
liquides c'est la même chose l'autre si
c'est de mettre un petit peu de liquide
à toutes les 5 10 minutes
si on peut noter la bouteille d'eau un
proche c'est super important d'apporter
des choses qu'on aime puis comme on va
apprécier dans la randonnée il ya pas
une salade ni un sandwich mis en sac de
riz d'insectes qui est meilleur que
quand on a marché puisqu'on arrive puis
qu'on est devant la vue ou sous l'arbre
ou cc du grand grand bonheur
françois-xavier guide de montagne et ex
chef
oui on a senti comme quelque chose en
bas de la montagne
salut ça va venir à eau de la montagne
sea launch pour vous autres je vous ai
préparé par minute et sandwichs grecs
sont encore pau 5 gt rien avocat pour
continuer tomates sur un pain le vin et
noah croissant avec mr est le chip cox
ou mousse de petra qui d'un plat avec
confit de canard et pleurotes ainsi que
de poivrons rouges route truc
ok règles de base pour les sandwichs
trois ingrédients qui on se rase pas
plus la tête que ça on cherche pas fait
de progrès d'amalgamé monique catta ne
trouve pas ça coûte plus rien ça goûte
brun donc je préfère y avait vraiment
avec des belles choses qui s'amalgament
bien pour moi dans ma tête il faut
éveiller les sens parce qu'en tant d'eau
souvent bon pour plein de raisons la
fatigue du faux l'épuisement la chaleur
comme aujourd'hui tu peux avoir une
certaine paresse pour vouloir manger
alors que l'alimentation super important
donc pour moi on mange beaucoup être les
yeux on voyage beaucoup et c'est ensuite
avec les textures donc j'essaie de jouer
avec ça là dessus vous rejoignez parce
que ce que nathalie 10,1 c'est magique
quelque chose qui va se faire plaisir
sinon vous mangerez pop n'aurait pas
fait
c'est d'autant plus important pour les
débutants quand tu dis de la période
s'installe bien il ya aussi la
motivation il ya des personnes qu'on va
réussir à mener au sommet de la montée
avec la promesse du lac
hu la salade ces betteraves et donc ce
serait quand même un classique on
s'entend betteraves pommes vertes
ok l'idée est qu'aujourd'hui il fait 30
degrés aujourd'hui si humide plus sage
de 14 ce qui effraie jeu question
puisqu'il pesant les acides pas une
salade composée en mayonnaise la
préservation donc je savais qu'une
betteraves marinées pomme verte et pas
qu'en grille et donc pagnol gris que
j'ai fait avec du paprika et un petit
miel de trèfle au saas et 90% de l'eau
serait considéré par maintenant qu'on
mange avancer les crudités les verdures
les légumes super important les fruits
ben moi je m'en plaindre avec toi
alors si vous le voulez bien on va
redescendre de notre montagne près les
bancs de dessin d'autant plus que le
vent s'est alors nous je cite
cinquante minutes gauchiste grec
j'utilise en randonnée donc d'abord ce
qu'on au sarrasin et je les mélange avec
des amandes grillées puis chocolat
chocolat noir sinon un petit classique
dorado c'est une recette de grand-mère
crise avec des d'attaché si peu beaucoup
de beurre et du miel et que j'étais roth
et le petit dernier et se transporte
très vite par son aspect compact compte
un pain aux bananes
j'aime bien ça pour justement à
compléter l'apport énergétique pendant
la journée puis à voir le principal
c'est de toujours manger fréquemment un
petit peu parti peut donc on s'assume
pas non plus une grosse portion parce
que comme autant de gestion parce que
nous affaiblir puisque leur être
concentré sur l'estomac mais de manger
régulièrement comme celui ci pourra
jamais tomber en coulisse émis ou en
perte d'énergie
enfin ce qu'a fait avec mais bouchées
sucrées le savoir tron et sans se
tromper
après une fin de rando merci vous
revenez avant d'aller chine
le baiser
[Musique]